Tuesday night's Mega Millions lottery
drawing will be for the biggest jackpot
in US history an estimated 1.6 billion
dollars the prize grew to a billion on
Friday but no one matched all of last
night's numbers 15 23 53 65 70 and the
Mega Ball 7 and that means we all still
have a shot tonight's Mega Millions
jackpot is an estimated annuitize 1
billion dollars let's see if I can make
you a billionaire tonight
but there was no winner and what had
become the largest Mega Millions jackpot
since the game began in 2002 the odds of
hitting it big one in 300 2.5 million
lines formed across the country
yesterday as people bought tickets for a
shot at what was the second largest
lottery prize in US history
1 billion there hasn't been a Mega
Millions jackpot winner since July and
now officials say the jackpot would soar
to tie the all-time record of 1.6
billion dollars by Tuesday there is good
news for one lucky player in Morgan Hill
California we're at this gas station a
ticket matching five of six numbers was
purchased it's one of 15 tickets that's
good for a million dollars
but hitting it big doesn't always mean
sustaining the lifestyle according to
the Certified Financial Planner Board of
standards nearly one-third of lottery
winners declare bankruptcy
that's why CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger says it's important to
plan ahead to assemble a team of an
attorney and accountant and investment
advisor
sure take a little bit of money and have
some fun but you work towards your goals
your objectives and you make sure that
you don't go nuts
especially early on sometimes easier
said than done I'm guessing and if
someone wins Tuesday's jackpot they will
have the option to choose between the
1.6 billion a billion annuity or 904
million dollars in cash and then pay the
tax if you feel lucky today you can try
tonight's Powerball drawing that is 470
million dollars I've assembled my team
money I'm ready you didn't you didn't
get a single number did you yeah this
just tells you how hard this actually is
I'm sorry sorry missions right but
there's no it's 1.6 bit I'm speechless
and if I win Powerball tonight I'll
share yeah okay I'm right I've got my
team I know how to speak money
all right that's never the problem well